RONALD SMITH: I put the
word--
the number seven billion
there because
according to what I read in the
newspaper, this was the
weekend where the world's
population just increased past
seven billion.
So it's kind of an important
day in terms of world
population.
I'm going to talk about
population a little bit a week
or two from now when we're
talking about global warming
issues and environmental
issues.
But every scientist who's looked
at this issue would
probably define the holding
capacity of the planet, in
other words the number of people
that could live here
sustainably.
Everyone would define it
differently depending on how
they do the calculation.
My guess would be that the
holding capacity of the
planet's probably about
half that number.
Probably about three
or four billion.
Now, I may be way off on that,
but by my estimate we've long
since shot past the holding
capacity, which means that
we're basically using
up resources
that cannot be renewed.
So eventually something will
have to adjust either a very
different kind of living or
come down to a different
population.
Anyway, it's a troublesome
number.
What else?
Ah well we got to experience
our first nor'easter.
It was quite exciting.
Of course, one of the remarkable
things about these
storms, they come up the coast,
but they end up mixing
warm and cold air.
So you get the warm air coming
from the south with lots of
water vapor being lifted,
producing lots of
precipitation.
And yet the cold air comes down
from the north, from the
west side of the storm, wraps
around, and allows you to keep
that snow, which was formed
aloft by the ice phase
mechanism, allows you to
keep it as snow all
the way to the ground.
So even in this time of the
season, which is generally not
so cold, we had pretty good
snowfalls because the cold air
down from Canada allowed that
snow to keep as snow as it
fell all the way
to the ground.
The unusual thing about it was
it was a little bit earlier
than we typically have
nor'easters.
And that combined with the fact
that as the last 20 or 30
years have gone by, we've gotten
warming in New England,
which has kept the leaves
on the trees later
and later in later.
So in my recollection, this was
the first real nor'easter
that's come while all of the,
or most of the leaves were
still on the trees.
20 years ago, the leaves
were off the trees
easily two weeks ago.
Mid-October everything was down,
and now we still have
the leaves and now we get
our first nor'easter.
So it's a subtle indication,
maybe not so subtle, that
things are changing when you
can get a nor'easter coming
while the leaves are
still on the trees.
Interesting.
Any comments on that?
Anybody get out and try
skiing in the snow?
It was very wet, wasn't it?
So more of a sloppy snow
than anything else.
Any questions before we
get started today?
OK.
Well we had a little bit
to finish up on our
discussion of ice.
We hadn't quite finished the
mountain glacier section, so
I've gone going back
to this first
diagram from that section.
I wanted to remind you
about the definition
of a tidewater glacier.
That's when a glacier comes down
to the sea so that pieces
can break off and
form icebergs.
And some, of course, don't
get down that far.
Maybe I'll get the lights
off for this.
An interesting set of glaciers
is the North and South
Patagonian Icefields down
in the Southern Andes.
The North Patagonian Ice Sheet
is here, the Southern one is
here, it's larger.
And many of them actually calve
off their glaciers in
these big lakes to the
east into Argentina.
So if you were to go down there
and sign on to a tourist
boat that would take you up to
the calving glaciers, they
would be in these lakes for the
most part, rather than in
the fjords coming in from
the Pacific Ocean.
So that's kind of an
interesting place.
But remember, they're calving
in fresh water there.
They're not really-so I guess
I wouldn't really call them
tidewater glaciers, although you
could argue it either way.
They're calving into water,
but it's fresh water lakes
rather than seawater
with tides.
Flying over it, you get to see
these snow-covered mountains,
you get to see some of the ice
breaking up into crevasses as
they begin to flow
over a bend.
Wherever they've got a drop
over a sudden break in the
slope, they often break up into
these deep crevasses.
And of course, they're covered
with snow, but if you were to
fall into that, you fall down 50
or 100 meters and be lost.
But you can see the flow
streaks, these medial moraines
follow it down to where
the calving occurs.
It's a bad picture
from an aircraft.
There's a lake there and
the icebergs are
calving into the lake.
You see it here as well.
You see these various moraines,
medial moraines
going down and then they
break off into the
little lake down there.
Now, there's been a trend in the
amount of ice in mountain
glaciers, and it's negative
most places.
This shows a number of different
parts around the
world where you've got mountain
glaciers, and it's
kept track of their
mass since 1960.
The units here are meters
of water equivalent.
So it's not how deep the snow or
the ice is on the glacier,
but if you were to melt
it into liquid how
deep it would be.
That's a convenient reference
because snow can be of
different densities, and even
compacted snow, depending on
how tight it's been compacted,
may not reach the
full density of ice.
So for this kind of mass balance
calculation, it's more
convenient to, in the end,
describe it as a loss in a
depth of water equivalent.
A little bit hard to follow the
colors, but in Patagonia
where I was just pointing, we've
had some of the largest
drops, 35 meters of water
equivalent, a decrease in the
thickness of those mountain
glaciers.
Alaska and the coast
mountains have
decreased rapidly as well.
And the Northwestern USA, for
example, Glacier National
Park, named after its glaciers,
is having one of the
most rapid decreases.
The word there is if you want to
see the glaciers in Glacier
National Park you better go
there in the next five years
because they're diminishing
pretty rapidly.
However, there are some
glaciers that are not
changing very much.
For example, in the arctic, and
again, I'm not sure of the
color codes here, but it looks
like Europe and the Andean
glaciers this would be the
Southern Andes, this would be
the rest of the Central Andes
they are not changing so
dramatically, at least not
until the last few years.
So it's a mixed story, but
mostly strongly negative for
the trends on those
mountain glaciers.
To wrap-up I wanted to go back
and look at Greenland.
We've already talked about it
a little bit, but just to
summarize some of the
changes that are
occurring in Greenland.
Here are some of the glaciers
coming off of the main
Greenland Ice sheet as a
function of time from 2000
till almost the present day.
We looked at the Jakobshaven
one.
We've spent some time
talking about those.
I haven't shown you
the other ones.
Oh, I did show you the
Petermann up in the
northwestern part.
For the most part these
are negative.
Some very strongly negative,
some not so strongly.
But generally the glaciers
are retreating.
This is in units of
square kilometers.
So the base of it, it's not
keeping track of thickness
now, but the area
as it decreases.
Generally negative.
And we saw Petermann's
glacier.
So when that drops off, they
decrease the area estimate of
the Petermann glacier.
And some would argue well that's
not a significant loss
because that'll refill
eventually, but that's how
they've done the calculation.
And then we looked at
Jakobshaven before and saw
that its calving front was
retreating with time as well,
and that shows up on
the time plot also.
Now, there's another thing
we can investigate about
Greenland, and that is the
amount of surface area up on
the ice sheet that has
meltwater in the
middle of the summer.
And what's shown--so you can
fly a satellite over, look
down, and by the way light
reflects off the ice sheet,
you could determine whether or
not the snow is wet whether
it's got meltwater mixed
in with the snow.
And in 1992 the pale area was
shown to have melt water in
the warm season.
And now, 2005, even this
deeper red area.
It's only the diminishing white
area that is free of
melt water, and that's an
indication that the climate is
changing as well.
What happens to that melt water,
some of it just stays
there and refreezes
the next winter.
Some of it runs off in this
rather remarkable called a
moulin, which is basically a
hole that develops in the ice
sheet that allows surface waters
that are melting in the
summer to drain and fall
a distance of perhaps a
kilometer or so down to the
base of the glacier.
And then it'll flow along
the base of the
glacier out to the sea.
So this is an example of
one of those moulins.
Up on the Greenland ice sheet,
water then draining down into
this hole that takes it down to
the bottom of the glacier.
Any questions on that?
It's a summertime, of course.
Recently we've got a new
technology to keep track of
what's happening to Greenland
and other
things around the world.
It's called the GRACE satellite,
and maybe you can
make out the acronym here.
Gravity Recovery And
Climate Experiment.
That's GRACE.
And it consists of two
satellites moving around the
planet very close to each other
with a laser beam going
from one to the other doing
accurate laser ranging.
So you know within a millimeter
or so the distance
between those two satellites
as they move.
Well, as the Earth is not
uniform in its density, the
continents have mass, other
things have mass
concentrations that make the
gravity field of the planet a
little bit irregular.
And by sending a satellite
around that feels that
gravity, and keeping track of
how the distance between the
two satellites varies during
the orbit, they can map out
these gravitational anomalies
around the
surface of the Earth.
And this is an exaggerated what
they've done is take a
globe, and in three dimensions
kind of made it nobly so that
it shows you where the higher
mass concentrations are.
So this kind of irregular
gravity field is what GRACE
can detect as it goes around.
Now that satellit's all that's
been in orbit for a few years
now, and one of the applications
of it is to look
at not just the gravity
concentrations near Greenland,
but how they've been
changing in time.
That's what shown
in this diagram.
So two plots are shown, one for
Southeast Greenland, that
would be this area here.
The other for Northwest
Greenland up here.
The time runs from 2002 to
2010, and this is the
centimeter of water equivalent
thickness removed from,
ormissing from that part
of Greenland over
that period of time.
And for Southeast Greenland,
putting a straight line
through there, you get about
minus eight centimeters per
year of water equivalent loss.
And for Northwest Greenland
it's about minus seven
centimeters per year.
So the two values are
roughly consistent.
That tells you that the overall
mass of the Greenland
ice sheet is decreasing.
You can do calculations with
these numbers and figure out
how long it would take before it
would all be lost. It'd be
quite a number of years because
these ice layers are
quite thick, a kilometer
or more.
But nevertheless, it
represents quite
a bit of mass loss.
And when that water melts and
goes into the sea, of course,
that raises sea level
a little bit.
And that's a calculation
you can do as well.
If you know the area of
Greenland and how much this is
decreasing per unit time, you
can use the surface area of
the oceans to compute how
much that is going
to raise sea level.
Any questions on that?
Well that's the end of the story
on modern ice, current
ice on the planet.
We could take a few minutes if
there are any questions about
any of the things that I've
covered with regards to ice in
the climate system.
Anything?
Yeah, Julia.
Student: So glaciers are always
associated with mountains?
PROFESSOR: That's right.
I would say the word glacier
usually implies moving ice.
Moving gravitationally.
So if you've got an ice sheet
like Greenland, and through
the gaps, like here and here,
where the ice can squeeze out
and come down to sea level,
that would be a glacier.
You wouldn't refer to
this as a glacier.
This is an ice sheet.
But where it's squeezing and
flowing down to sea level,
that would be a glacier.
Or if you have a mountain
glacier, a small mountain
glacier with sliding
gravitationally, that would be
a glacier as well.
So just don't use it with
respect to a large ice sheet
and you'll be safe on the
terminology side of things.
Other questions on this?
Well we're going to shift
gears a little bit.
We're going to talk about
how climate has been
changing with time.
And for this you should
be reading
Chapter 13 in your book.
The author of the textbook has
done a good job with 13.
He's made a little different set
of choices than I've made
about what to emphasize.
But I think the combination of
the two, Chapter 13 in Ahrens,
and my presentation here today,
and this'll spill over
into Wednesday, will give you a
good introduction to how the
climate is changing
on the Earth.
I've made a decision to
focus on the last
five million years.
And the reason for that
well there are really
three reasons for that.
One is the continents have
pretty much been in their
present position for the last
five million years.
So we don't have to
worry about the
continents moving around.
Second of all, this has been
the period of time in our
planet when humans have been
evolving to our current form.
So it's not so distant in the
past that we're not engaged in
it as a species.
This is a period of time when
we have been coming on to,
evolving to our present form.
And I guess third, we're
looking for a period of
geologic history where there's
been significant change in
climate in order to make the
subject interesting.
But also, one of the reasons for
studying past climates is
to provide a context for
future climate change.
And to provide a good context
for future climate change, you
would like to look at a period
of Earth history that had
significant climate change.
And we certainly have it over
the last five million years.
So that's the reason why I've
decided to focus just on the
last five million years.
There's a number of
subcategories or subjects I'm
going to be treating
today and tomorrow.
Today we'll probably only get
through maybe the first two or
three of these.
We're going to start with a
brief overview of the climate
of the last five
million years.
How many of you--remind
me, how many have
had a geology course?
Just a few of you.
So you know something about
this time scale, and I've
mentioned it once or twice
before as well.
This is the geologic
time scale.
The Earth is something like five
or six billion years old.
This goes almost back
to that level.
The Precambrian is where we
didn't have life in the form
that would leave a
fossil record.
Nothing with bones or shells
or anything like that.
There was life there, and
there's certain types of
physical fossils that are
left, but not the actual
remains of the organisms.
Then you go through a series of
rapid evolution as you come
up through to the
present time.
We're not going to talk
about dinosaurs.
The dinosaurs died out
right about there.
Probably with an impact from
a large meteorite.
Instead we're going
to focus just on
these last three periods.
The Pliocene, the Pleistocene,
and Holocene, taking us from
approximately five million
years up to the present.
I showed you this plate
tectonics diagram once before,
coming up in time newer, newer,
newer, and newer.
This takes us to the Cretaceous,
which is here, 65
million years ago.
We're jumping up now factor
of 10 younger than that.
So pretty much the continents
are going to be in their
current state for this last
five million years.
So we don't have to worry
about any of this.
If a continent has a record of
a different climate, it's not
because it was at a different
latitude.
It's because the climate was
actually different on Earth at
that time, not just the
continents sliding around
under the climate zones.
Questions there?
All right.
So just a few words about
these three periods.
The mid-Pliocene, 3.3 to three
million years before present,
similar common locations today,
but a significantly
higher global temperature, maybe
two to three degrees
Celsius for the average
global temperature.
Much more remarkable than that,
though, was that the
high latitudes were much warmer
than they are today.
There was a little bit of
ice on Greenland, but
not a real ice sheet.
Because of that lack of ice, sea
level was about 25 meters
higher than it is today.
And for these reasons, there is
quite a flurry of research
going on right now about the
Pliocene, because it's a
possible analog for what the
Earth will be like about 100
years from now with
global warming.
I'm going to talk about global
warming next week.
But this has really excited a
lot of interest, this idea
that maybe there was a period
in the past we could look at
to see our future in a sense.
Now whether that turns out to be
an accurate analog, I would
say remains to be seen.
But that's one of the reasons
why there's so much current
activity about the Pliocene.
Yes?
Student: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So a million years
before present.
A million years before
present.
These are some of the mammals
we had in the Pliocene era.
Saber-toothed tiger and
the woolly mammoth.
As I say, no dinosaurs.
That was 60 million years ago.
The Pliocene vegetation now,
there's no legend on this
diagram, but the author wanted
to make the point that the
normal forests that we have here
at mid-latitudes, at that
time extended all the way up
into the Canadian archipelago
up into Alaska.
Areas that are now tundra had
forests very much like the
ones we have here
in Connecticut.
So it really was a period of
time when temperatures were
much warmer at the higher
latitudes than they are today.
Then we'll jump to the
Pleistocene, which is 2.6
million years ago up to
just 12,000 years ago.
One of the problems with
Paleoclimatology is we've got
to deal with these vast
stretches of time.
It's a little bit hard sometimes
to conceive of how
long ago that was and
how recent this was.
But we'll be working on that
today and next time trying to
give you all a better
understanding on how these
time scales work.
The Pleistocene was possibly
the coldest period in Earth
history, although there have
been discussions of periods of
time hundreds of millions
of years ago that
may have been colder.
But at least in recent Earth
history, in the last, say, 100
million years or even 200
million years, probably this
was the coldest period in that
part of Earth history.
As we'll see, there were lower
carbon dioxide concentrations
in the atmosphere than
there are today.
And throughout this two and a
half million year period,
there were periodic advances and
retreats of ice sheets and
mountain glaciers.
So it wasn't a single ice age,
in a sense it was a large
number of ice ages with warm--
brief warm spells in between.
If you averaged, however, it
certainly was a very cold
period of time.
Surprising, because we just
came out of the Pliocene,
which was warmer than
it is today.
Then we go into the Pleistocene,
which was much
colder, and then we're going
to bounce back out and talk
about modern climate.
I've written here Milankovitch
pacing because the advance and
retreat of these ice sheets
seems to have been controlled
by slight adjustments in the
Earth's orbital parameters.
The so-called Milankovitch
theory of climate change, and
I'll talk about that.
And this period of time, 2.6 to
the present, includes most
of human evolution, at least the
species that have homo in
front of them, as I'll show
you in just a minute.
And the Last Glacial Maximum,
the last of these ice sheet
advances, was about 14,000
years before present.
And it was just after that that
I'll take the official
end of the Pleistocene period.
So I'm kind of defining the end
of it as being the end of
the last glacial advance.
Here is a diagram showing
human evolution.
There's a time scale up there
in millions of years ago.
So here is today, one million,
two million, three
million years ago.
The prefix A, Australopithecus
is on these brown species
indicators.
And then you get to the homo
prefix, and that really takes
you from two million years
up to the present.
Homosapiens, however, are only
in the last couple of hundred
thousand years.
So climatologically then, the
Pleistocene goes from about
here to about there, getting a
little bit of Homosapiens in
it, and most of the other
ancestors of modern man.
So be sure you have some
understanding of this when
we're thinking about
paleoclimate so you can make
the necessary connections
between human evolution and
the change in climate.
Any questions on that?
If there's any anthropology
majors or people who have had
an anthropology course, keep
me honest on these things.
I'm not much of an expert on
human evolution, but don't
feel afraid to speak
out if I say
something wrong about that.
I'm going to come back to this
diagram later on, but it suits
the present purpose as well.
It happens to be data from a
Vostok ice core, and I will
describe later how this data is
gathered and interpreted.
But for the time being let's
take it at face value.
Here's a plot of temperature
change from present, from the
present day back to
400,000 years ago.
So here is today, and of course
by definition, present
change--temperature change from
present, that's right
about zero, because here's
the present day.
About 10,000 years ago and
earlier, we were in a much
colder period of time.
That's the last glacial
period.
Then there was another brief
interglacial period, about
130,000 years ago.
Then a long glacial period,
another brief
interglacial, and so on.
So when I talk about the
Pleistocene as being a period
of ice advances and retreats
and significant climate
change, this is what
I'm talking about.
On average it was much colder
than the present day.
Typically four or five or six
degrees Celsius colder than
the present day.
But there were other
interglacials.
There are other brief
periods of warmth.
We're in one today, and about
every 100,000, 125,000
thousand years back through this
record, there was another
brief interglacial.
That will give you a sense for
what I mean by this great
variability that occurred within
the Pleistocene period.
At the Last Glacial Maximum,
in other words, right about
here, about 20,000 years ago,
although you could take it a
little more recent than that,
LGM, is the abbreviation for
Last Glacial Maximum, this
was the distribution of
continental ice sheets.
It doesn't show Antarctica, but
Antarctica still had its
full ice sheet at that
time, and Greenland.
But now look, in addition,
you've got an even larger ice
sheet over North America
called the
Laurentide ice sheet.
And then a large one up over
Scandinavia and Northern
Russia as well.
So the number, or the aerial
extent of large continental
ice sheets was much larger
14,000, 15,000, 20,000 years
ago than it is today
at the end of the
Last Glacial Maximum.
So really a dramatically
different climate
then we have today.
This has been one of the biggest
paradigm shifts in the
Earth sciences in the last
200 years was to convince
ourselves, other scientists,
and finally the general
public, that this recent
period was so different
climatologically than
the one today.
If you go back and read the
scientific literature from the
period 1900, 1910, 1920, there
were violent arguments in the
scientific literature about
whether this could really be
true, that this short time ago
there could have been massive
ice sheets over the
continents.
Now we're certain it's true.
We have many, many lines of
evidence that convinced us of
that, but it was quite a
big deal at the time.
Then the third geologic period
that I want you to be familiar
with is the Holocene.
This is defined as a period
from 12,000 years before
present to the present day.
It is a current interglacial
period.
In other words, the current
non-glacial period.
It has modern humans, so
development of agriculture, a
nearly constant climate, and
nearly steady sea level during
that period of time.
So if you're looking for a
reference point from which to
consider or compute climate
change, this
is a possible candidate.
Now, it's only 12,000 years,
but still, that's quite a
large time.
And for some purposes, that
might be a good reference
point for defining
climate change.
But be careful, not everyone
will agree with you on that.
Some people might say no, you
want to, perhaps, go back a
much longer period of time and
integrate over all of those
fluctuations in the Pleistocene,
or maybe even
include part of the
Pliocene in your
definition of a normal climate.
This will haunt us, this idea of
what would be the usual or
the normal climate.
It's almost an unanswerable
question.
Climate has changed so
dramatically over geologic
history that it's real hard to
find the time that you could
consider normal.
This might be the best
chance for that.
Questions there?
OK so there we have the
Pliocene, the Pleistocene, and
the Holocene, at least a brief
introduction to those.
Oh, here's a plot of the
Holocene temperatures.
This is thousands of years
before present, so this goes
back to 12,000 years, which is
the beginning of the Holocene.
Temperature--there's a lot of
different proxies that are
considered here, and they all
give somewhat different
interpretations of
past climates.
But if we take a look at the
thick black curve, which is
the average of all of the
different proxies, here we are
coming out of the last ice age,
reaching a value about
10,000 years ago, which remains
roughly constant till
the present day.
However, these fluctuations
have excited a lot of
discussion.
For example, this slightly
warmer period here is often
referred to as the Climatic
Optimum between about 8,000
and 5,000 years ago.
So some would argue when I say
that the the Holocene climate
was constant.
It wasn't exactly constant.
There were some fluctuations
within it.
So that's step one, getting
those three time periods out
on the table.
There's lots of paleoclimate
methods.
We're not going to have time
to talk about these.
But I want to spend the rest
of the period today talking
about geomorphology.
That is looking at
the landscape
to deduce past climates.
In a way this is the
most fun because
we can do it ourselves.
As we drive around the country,
look out the car
window, we can begin to see
these landscape features that
can be interpreted as evidence
of climate change.
So I want to spend quite a bit
of time on this because it's
the one that we can
really have fun
with and do it ourselves.
I'm going to focus on surface
evidence of the Pleistocene
ice ages, and look particularly
at these five
geomorphologic features.
A terminal moraine is that pile
of debris that marks the
end of a glacier.
Remember, a glacier is moving,
carrying material along
underneath it, melting
at the front.
So it's like a conveyor belt.
It's bringing material and then
the glacier leaves, but
the material piles up.
So if a glacier has a fixed
terminus for a number of
decades, it will build up a pile
of rubble, rock, and soil
at the end of it.
And then if that glacier were
to retreat, you'd have no
glacier here, but you would
have that terminal moraine
left as a marker, as evidence
of where that glacier was.
So that's the importance of
the terminal moraine.
It shows you where the previous
end of a glacier was,
if it was there at least for
several decades or a few
hundred years.
Here's one, here's a mountain
glacier coming down into a
lake, and here at the other end
is the terminal moraine.
So at an earlier time, this
glacier filled in the lake and
ended right there, and the
debris it was carrying
underneath it piled up
to form that moraine.
So we see it today, we can say
ah, that glacier has retreated
because it's snout used to be
right there at that location.
That's the beauty of the
terminal moraine.
It gives you this recent history
of how far the glacier
had extended.
For scale, here's a fellow
standing on top of a pile of
rubber--of rubble, rather.
The glacier's nowhere
to be seen, it's
retreated up the valley.
But this is where the snout
of that the glacier was.
Now, there's some other things
that happens underneath a
large ice sheet that get
revealed when the ice finally
melts and moves back.
Well, OK, I've said it
wrong, didn't I?
Moved back.
A glacier never moves back.
It's terminus may retreat, but
the glacier, the ice itself,
is either stationary or
is moving forward.
When you go into a warm period
and the glaciers retreat, they
never do it by sliding that
glacier back up the valley.
Be very clear on that.
It's only that the apparent
end of it may
seem to move back.
But the ice will continue to be
flowing from left to right
here as the terminus moves
from right to left.
So be very careful about your
terminology on this.
Here's a terminal moraine
left behind by that.
There's an esker, that I'll
define in just a moment, and
there are some drumlins that I
will define in just a moment.
An esker is a river flowing
underneath the ice, underneath
the ice sheet, that gets partly
filled up with debris.
And then when the ice sheet
melts, you're left with this
little pile of debris
where the river was.
So the river, instead of being
a depression in this case as
we're used to seeing, because
there was a river up inside a
glacier, actually leaves an
elevated tongue marking where
that river was.
Here's a nice example of one
up in Manitoba of an esker.
So an ice sheet covered this,
there was a river underneath
the ice, and the debris that
collected in that sub-ice
river, then when the ice
melted away left
you with that esker.
Glacial striations, you can see
them here in New England,
scrapes on bedrock indicating
that a glacier has slid over
that particular part of rock.
Usually underneath the ice
there are chunks of rock
embedded in the ice.
And so you're scraping these
embedded chunks over the
bedrock, leaving a
scraping mark.
You can tell what direction
the glacier was moving.
Well it's hard to distinguish
that from that, but at least
you know it was either moving
in that direction or in that
direction from the direction of
those glacial striations.
Sometimes they can be deeper
grooves, as you see in this
piece of rock here.
So that tells you that
a glacier has
scraped over this terrain.
The glacial erratic
are easy to spot.
A very large boulder sitting
on a bedrock that doesn't
match it in terms
of rock type.
So it's foreign.
It didn't come from here.
It's been moved from
some other place.
Now, if it was a small rock, you
could say well maybe water
could have moved that.
But if it gets to be this size
there's nothing there for
scale, but that's two or three
meters in height water could
not have moved that
large rock.
So that had to be a glacier
that moved it.
The word erratic means it's a
large boulder in a place that
has different rock type than
the boulder itself.
So it didn't come from there,
it was carried in
by somewhere else.
Sometimes you can trace these
back and find out
where they came from.
That will give you a direction
of ice motion.
Here's another in Denali
National Park and in Calgary,
examples of glacial erratics.
You can spot these pretty
easily up in Canada.
A drumlin is a hill that has
been shaped by a glacier
sliding over it.
It's got usually a steep end,
and a less steep end,
indicating the ice flow,
in this case, goes
from left to right.
So it scrapes off material here,
and then deposits it on
this long tail back here.
Here's a drumlin seen
from the air.
So the glacier was flowing
from left to
right in this case.
Here's a bunch of them, I guess
the farmers had planted
fields in the flat terrain, but
they've left forests on
some of these drumlins.
And then here's a field of
drumlins up in Canada seen
from a satellite.
And it's pretty easy to guess
which way the ice flow was.
It was from upper left to lower
right forming all of
those drumlins.
So that's a little bit of what
you can look for as you drive
around to convince yourselves
that there was big ice on the
landscape not too long ago.
And this is what
it looked like.
So I want to spend a few slides
just describing what
the Earth was like during this
Last Glacial Maximum.
Roughly 20,000 to 14,000
years before present.
In addition to Greenland and
Antarctica, there was this
giant Laurentide ice sheet.
An ice sheet on the West
Coast called the
Cordilleran ice sheet.
But look, Alaska was, at least
Northern Alaska was
still free of ice.
That's a bit of a surprise.
However, there are also large
ice sheets in Scandinavia and
Northern Russia as well.
When you look at the drumlins
and the glacial striations,
and the glacial erratics for the
Laurentide ice sheet, you
can work out a sense of motion,
how the ice was
moving, and this is what
you come up with.
The little arrows indicate what
local evidence tells us
about the direction of motion
of the ice sheet.
Down in our part of the
country, it was
from north to south.
But up in Northern Canada
actually, south to north.
So it seemed like there's a dome
of ice here with a center
somewhere around here, and the
ice is then spreading out
gravitationally away
from that center.
That's the view or that's the
vision you get when you see a
map like this.
Gravity is doing the spreading,
and the high point
must have been somewhere in
the middle here with ice
moving out in the different
directions.
One of the reasons they put
a different name on the
Cordilleran ice sheet is because
you see some eastern
movement here, which conflicts
with what the Laurentide ice
sheet movement has been.
So there must have been a seam
here along the Rockies where
those two ice sheets were
kind of butting up
against each other.
Questions on that?
That's the Laurentide
ice sheet.
Now, down here in New England,
we've got this remarkable
feature called Long Island to
look at, as well as a Martha's
Vineyard and Nantucket.
When the ice sheet came down
here, it moved offshore and
spent a long enough period
of time to build
up a terminal moraine.
Then retreated slightly
and built up
another terminal moraine.
So there are two terminal
moraines that now make up Long
Island, Martha's Vineyard
and Nantucket, as
well as Cape Cod.
Those are both--all those
features are basically
terminal moraines left over from
the Last Glacial Maximum.
So over New Haven here, we
probably still had several
hundred meters of ice sliding
southwards, but then it
tapered off, and the terminus
was roughly here, for a long
enough period of time to have
built up two substantial
terminal moraines at
those locations.
So we've got evidence right
outside our front door that
this ice sheet was overhead
not that many years ago.
Questions on that?
Well now, we need to get a
little more quantitative about
climate change.
I won't be able to finish this,
but let me say a few
words about it and then we'll
cut until Wednesday.
But we have to get
more quantitative
about climate change.
We have to have records that
we can go back uniformly in
time to see how things are
changing quantitatively.
One of the best ways to do
this is by looking at the
stable isotopes of water.
And I wanted to remind you about
what I mean by isotopes
and how we're going to use
them climatologically.
You remember that an isotope
of a chemical element is
defined as an analog to that
element that has an extra
neutron or more in the nucleus
to give it an added mass, but
without any change in its
electrical charge.
So for example, hydrogen is
normally one proton with
electrons going around it.
The most common isotope of
hydrogen is called deuterium.
It has a proton and a neutron
in its nucleus, so it's got
double the mass, but
the same charge.
The same charge means
it behaves
chemically like its parent.
But that extra mass makes
it behave a little bit
differently when it comes
to changing phase.
With oxygen, the dominant, let's
say the parent isotope
of oxygen has a mass of 16.
Eight protons, eight neutrons
in the nucleus.
However, it's still oxygen
if I add two more
neutrons to the nucleus.
Now it becomes oxygen 18.
These are the particular
isotopes I'm going to be
talking about next time with
respect to using--
looking for clues for climate
change, particularly deuterium
versus hydrogen, and oxygen
18 versus oxygen 16.
So I can make up new water
vapor molecules now.
If I make water from a
normal--two normal hydrogens
and a normal oxygen, it's going
to have a mass of 18 16
plus 1 plus 1, that's 18.
If I replace one of the
hydrogens with deuterium,
that's going to give water
with a mass of 19.
If instead, I keep the two
hydrogens as hydrogen, but
replace the oxygen 16 with
oxygen 18, I get a mass of 20.
Turns out that these heavier
isotopes of water have a
slightly lower vapor pressure.
This means they evaporate
more slowly and they
condense more readily.
And this is what gives
them--what provides to us
information about how the
hydrological cycle was working
in the past by looking at the
ratio of these two isotopes.
I'm out of time today, but
before Wednesday if you could
spend a few minutes reviewing
your high school and college
chemistry about the nature of
these isotopes, that'll put
you in a good position
to understand
the lecture on Wednesday.